MICHAEL WARE: For the
people who don't know,
what's the goal
of your movement?
MOHAMMAD: The goal of--
[laughing]
[all laughing]
It's obvious that the
goal of our movement
is to overthrow the
regime and bring
about a democratic,
pluralistic, secular, uh--
MICHAEL WARE: Right.
Regime change.
MOHAMMAD: Regime
change inside Iran.
But by what method?
MOHAMMAD: We pray God
that we can change
the regime absolutely
peacefully,
because we have enough martyrs.
120,000 of our
members and supporters
have been killed by
the regime, and we
don't want to add to this list.
We are trying to
increase the support
of Iranian people inside Iran.
Mm-hm.
Very much depends on
what will happen in Iran.
When I first met
you in Ashraf, I mean,
you had entire tank
battalions and brigades.
You had a fervent belief
that through military action
you could spark the
fire of revolution.
Have you abandoned that
now, the prospect of armed
resistance, armed revolution?
It's many years that
we have not been engaged
in any military activities--
MOHAMMAD: Yes.
--and that has been
publicly announced.
MICHAEL WARE: OK.
So why does a
political organization
still need to have a
paramilitary organization,
then?
I mean-- it has never
been a paramilitary--
MICHAEL WARE: Paramilitary--
- But--
MICHAEL WARE: Well,
you've had a political--
Well, that--
MICHAEL WARE: --face, and
you've had a military face.
- There was [inaudible].
- Yes.
You were very well armed.
You were very well trained.
As a fighting force, you were
a very impressive organization.
Exactly.
You have, what, 3,800 members
still in uniform, so to speak.
I mean--
MICHAEL WARE: Right?
Because they're in uniform.
No.
MICHAEL WARE: Basically.
- No.
- Not really.
This is not really--
MICHAEL WARE: What, not today?
- No, no.
Actually--
- No, they're not in uniform.
- Because once upon a--
I mean--
- There was a time that there--
- There was.
- There were.
But not anymore.
- No.
- No, no.
It's now a few years.
MICHAEL WARE: Nonetheless,
you still have not abandoned
the notion of armed resistance.
Should the moment arise,
should the opportunity
present itself--
If you ask me as a
matter of principle,
I believe the people's
right to resistance.
[inaudible]
But that's in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights.
That's in the
American independence.
You can see it everywhere.
- American Constitution.
Exactly.
Now he's gone all the way
to the American Constitution.
(LAUGHING) So that's
a matter of principle.